frais avec mes shows bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin alors on va parler d'un sondage
que vous avez réalisé pour public sénat
et la tribune un sondage sur les
français et leur mère à l' approche des
élections municipales est le premier
enseignement de ce sondage c'est le
sentiment de proximité
les français considèrent que le maire et
celui qui comprend le mieux les citoyens
pour 66% des sondés dans cette étude
oui absolument alors c'est pas une
nouveauté c'est un résultat classique
dans les études d'opinion mais c'est
mieux
un résultat qui est à nouveau mesuré
dans le cadre de cette élection
municipale on voit bien que en réalité
en france il ya deux types d lui d'un
côté les maires qui bénéficie d'une très
bonne image en raison de notamment de la
proximité mais aussi du travail qui est
accompli sur le terrain image très
positif très positif jugement sur le
travail accompli lui aussi très très
favorable et puis de l'autre côté il ya
tout le reste des autres élus qui eux
font l'objet d'une défiance d'une
méfiance d'une suspicion même
extrêmement extrêmement forte
donc on a bien ces deux types d'élus et
les maires sont les seuls à pouvoir
tirer leur épingle du jeu
mais pourquoi on dit souvent que les
maires sont apportés d'engueulades en
première ligne quand il ya des problèmes
locaux mais ça ne nuit pas à leur
popularité
non ça ne nuit pas précisément parce que
ce sont des élus de terrain
alors même si parfois ils peuvent
justement être l'objet d'une forme de
colère ils sont sur le terrain ils sont
présents on sait à qui s'adressait il
incarne véritablement la fonction c'est
peut-être pas le cas pour d'autres élus
qui apparaissent plus lointain alors
quand on regarde précisément les
chiffres et bien cette cote de
popularité en six mois elle a baissé de
10 points
elle est passée de 78 à 68 %
comment on explique cette chute alors on
explique sans doute par un effet qu est
liée à la campagne électorale vous avez
ce qui a été mesuré ya quelques mois
c'était l'image du dd mer d'une manière
générale depuis quelques ces quelques
semaines la campagne électorale se
déroule et on ne perçoit plus la
fonction mais on perçoit les personnes
qui incarnent cette fonction avec
éventuellement ceux qui peuvent succéder
ou remplacer le maire en place
tout ça crée ce petit affaiblissement
dont vous parlez mais tout de même 68 %
des français qui ont une bonne image des
maires c'est un résultat exceptionnel
mais ça reste quand même un socle
important
alors est-ce qu'on se dirige dans ces
élections municipales vers d'une manière
générale une prime au maire sortant
oui absolument c'est quelque chose qui
est très bien démontré dans l'ensemble
des études d'opinion précisément parce
que le jugement sur le travail qui a été
accompli au cours du mandat écoulé est
très bon les maires bien travailler
selon leurs administrés et puis
généralement on sait qu' il ya une prime
traditionnelle ressortant le l'exercice
du travail municipal c'est un exercice
qui se déroule sur le sur la longue
durée et souvent quand des projets sont
mises en place déployés au niveau
municipal un mandat n'est pas suffisant
donc les les citoyens ont tendance à
accorder plus facilement un deuxième
mandat voire un troisième mandat au
maire en place pour qu'il puisse mettre
en oeuvre leurs projets donc les
citoyens veulent s'inscrire localement
dans la durée c'est pas comme sur le
terrain national
non on n'observe pas du tout la tendance
au dégagisme c'est d'ailleurs une autre
spécificité des élections municipales
alors il faut attendre évidemment les
résultats de dimanche mais a priori
ce que ce que laisse que les études
annoncé plus tôt une reconduction de la
plupart des maires sortants
alors ce qui ressort également dans ce
sondage c'est le poids des enjeux à
nationaux dans l'élection municipale 54%
des personnes interrogées estiment que
la situation nationale va compter dans
leur vote
c'est étonnant parce qu'on dit souvent
que l'élection municipale c'est avant
tout une élection locale
oui c'est une élection locale à 54%
c'est un chiffre qui est majoritaire
mais c'est pas une majorité débordante
sont évidemment les enjeux locaux qui
qui qui qui reste très important au
niveau municipal mais on ne peut pas
désincruster l'élection municipale d'un
contexte national contexte qui est
marqué par le corps un navire eu ce
contexte qui est marquée aussi par la
contestation de la loi retraites est
justement là sur la loi retraite 43% des
personnes interrogées estiment que cette
réforme des retraites va entrer en jeu
dans leurs votes c'est à dire qu'on peut
se diriger vers un vote sanction
cette fois ci sur la république en
marche oui il peut y avoir une partie de
votre sanction mais c'est toujours le
cas pour le pouvoir politique qui est en
place dans le cadre des élections
intermédiaires comme le sont les
élections municipales où les élections
départementales ou régionales par
exemple toujours aussi une façon
d'adresser un message au pouvoir
national alors on voit les enjeux
nationaux sont quand même important pour
ce vote municipal mais les candidats des
différents partis politiques essayent de
gommer l'étiquette de leur parti comment
elle explique oui alors ça c'est aussi
c'est un phénomène qui est apparue il ya
plusieurs ya plusieurs années c'est pas
la première élection municipale dans
lequel nous observons ce type de de
volonté de masquer un petit peu son
appartenance politique
alors on l'expliquent de plusieurs
manières d'abord les grands partis
politiques pâtissent d'une forme de
discrédit au niveau national on l'a bien
vu en 2017 avec
justement ce mouvement de dégager ce
dont nous parlions et puis le deuxième
élément c'est cette volonté pour les
candidats de s'inscrire au niveau local
dans l'action locale au service des
citoyens et donc d'effacer tout ce qui
pourrait relever d'une appartenance
partisane et de se montrer plus
rassembleur alors en parler des
principales préoccupations des citoyens
par rapport à leur mère et c'est la
sécurité qui arrive en tête pour 39% des
personnes interrogées
là encore on a l'impression que c'est
pas vraiment nouveau non c'est pas une
nouveauté c'était déjà le cas souvenez
vous il ya une vingtaine d'années lors
des élections municipales de 2001 qui
avait permis à la droite à l'époque au
rpr et à l'udf de reconquérir toute une
série de villes
la sécurité c'est un enjeu local
extrêmement fort mais il y en a d'autres
la question de la propreté la question
des finances locales
je dirais qu'on est là face à une
myriade d'enjeux qui vont
entrée en compte dans le vote des
électeurs dimanche et on parle beaucoup
d'écologie dans cette campagne les
candidats écologistes ont le vent en
poupe dans les sondages mais on ne voit
pas trop dans cette étude
l'écologie ressortir dans les
principales préoccupations il ya un
petit peu les espaces verts mais pas
trop l'écologie n'ont pas trop
l'écologie alors parce que c'est un
sondage qui a réalisé au niveau national
on sait aussi que l'écologie est
davantage une priorité pour les
personnes qui habitent dans les grandes
métropoles dans les grandes villes
évidemment la france étant un pays
composé en grande partie de communes
rurales c'est un enjeu qui est un peu
lisse et au niveau national mais dans
les grandes villes cette question des
espaces verts cette question de
l'environnement est un enjeu qui qui
s'est affirmé au cours des dernières
années donc ça veut dire que dans les
territoires plus ruraux
on est moins préoccupés par l'écologie
on n'est pas moins préoccupé d'une
manière générale mais c'est un enjeu qui
va compter moins que d'autres enjeux il
ya également la question du maintien des
services publics on en est à parler par
exemple l'année dernière pendant la
crise délits d gilet jaune ça c'est une
préoccupation également importantes au
niveau local oui c'est une préoccupation
très très forte
alors là pour le coup c'est une vraie
préoccupation dans l'est dans les
territoires ruraux avec une fonction
très importante pour ces services
publics de maintien du lien social de
maintien aussi de l'activité économique
dans ces territoires
et puis les citoyens sont forcément
préoccupée par la question budgétaire
par l'argent et par la baisse des impôts
locaux
mais finalement il ya eu quand même la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation qui
va se décliner progressivement mais ils
veulent quand même que les impôts locaux
baissent
oui la question des finances le cas est
toujours une question très importante
pour les électeurs au moment d
au moment du vote lors des élections
municipales la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation ou la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation pour une grande partie
de la majorité de la population n'a pas
été forcément constaté par par
l'ensemble des électeurs néanmoins cette
préoccupation reste très très forte dans
l'électorat d'accord une préoccupation
qui est quand même forte on a parlé à
des enjeux nationaux sur ce scrutin est
ce que vous pensez que la crise du court
noué un virus peut avoir un impact sur
l'élection dimanche
c'est très difficile de le mesurer le
premier impact auquel on pense est un
impact sur la participation ça pourrait
pousser l'abstention tout cas être un
prétexte pour ceux qui ont d'ores et
déjà l'intention de de s'abstenir
c'est difficile de le mesurer d'abord
parce que l'abstention c'est toujours la
grande difficulté technique pour les
sondeurs on sait que c'est un mouvement
d'humeur en grande partie et puis
ensuite parce que la situation évolue
très rapidement puisque nous mesurons
aujourd'hui ne sera peut-être pas la
réalité du comportement électoral
dimanche
mais pour l'instant dans les mesures
actuelles on sait que à peu près un
tiers des français ne souhaitent pas
aller voter dimanche à cause du gros
navires us ça va quand même avoir un
impact fort sur ce scrutin
ça peut avoir un impact fort alors parmi
ceux là comme je le disais tout une
série d'abstentionnistes qui peuvent se
saisir de ce prétexte du coronavirus
pour justifier un comportement qui reste
encore perçu comme un comportement
incivique et donc avec toutes les
difficultés pour assumer ce type de
comportement dans le cadre d'une enquête
d'une enquête d'opinion mais mais on
voit aussi dans les études que ceux qui
se déclarent le plus inquiet à l'idée de
se rendre dans le bureau de vote
ce sont les plus jeunes donc ceux qui
sont encore le plus éloigné de
l'élection l'impact du coronavirus sur
les élections municipales et sur
l'abstention sur la participation
électorale
ça reste encore très très difficile de
l'établir précisément mais très
difficile à mesurer on va maintenant
parler de la campagne municipale à paris
puisque rachida dati organisé hier soir
un meeting à la salle gaveau à paris en
présence d'un soutien de poids l'ancien
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy
on va d'ailleurs écouter un extrait du
discours de nicolas sarkozy vous
imaginez mon émotion de revenir ici la
droite républicaine française
elle n'a d'avenir que ciel et populaire
que si elle est entendue par toutes les
catégories sociales et tant de fois
la droite s'est trompé en choisissant
telle ou telle catégorie
rachida c'est la capacité d'être entendu
par la france du peuple par la france
qui travaille par la france des vigiles
frédérick michaud est-ce que
l'engagement d'un ancien président de la
république ça peut peser et notamment
dans cette campagne parisienne alors ça
dépend du de l'ancien président de la
république nicolas sarkozy et reste une
figure tutélaire de la droite c'est le
dernier candidat de droite à être
parvenu à conquérir l'elysée ça reste
une grande référence et ce type de
soutien et de nature à resserrer
l'électorat de droite derrière derrière
sa candidate
mais disons que c'est un d'abord des
effets sur
sur l'électorat naturel de la candidate
rachida dati est pas sur l'ensemble de
l'électorat parisien
oui ça venait ça dépend de l'ancien
président la république imaginons qu'un
françois hollande vient de faire un
meeting avec anne hidalgo est ce que ça
pourrait apporter un effet positif alors
c'est difficile de le mesurer mais même
si le l'ancien président de la
république depuis qu'il a quitté
l'elysée a vu son image se rétablir
progressivement elle reste encore assez
mitigé dans l'opinion et on voit bien
que la candidate anne hidalgo n'a pas
sollicité son soutien officiellement en
tout cas alors on l'a entendu un dans
les mots de nicolas sarkozy il a
beaucoup insisté sur la droite proche du
peuple proche des classes populaires
est ce que rachida dati incarne cet
électorat populaire à paris alors nous
serons dimanche un camp nous regarderons
la composition de son électorat
le fait de bénéficier des soutiens des
catégories populaires c'est à dire des
employés et des ouvriers avaient été
l'une des composantes de la victoire
électorale de nicolas sarkozy en 2007
cette capacité précisément à agréger des
catégories populaires et puis des
catégories plus aisées les cadres les
professions intermédiaires et on voit
bien que depuis plusieurs années la
droite s'est coupé de ces catégories
populaires pardon qui en grande partie
se sont déplacés soit vers le
rassemblement national soit vers vers
l'abstention
il ya là sans doute la clé d'une re
compte d'une reconquête électorale pour
pour la droite
donc l'enjeu c'est ça c'est d'aller
chercher les classes populaires
notamment 2022 absolument
d'ores et déjà à des l'élection
municipal de 2020 dans les différents
scrutins qui vont se succéder jusqu'à
l'élection présidentielle et puis
évidemment en 2022 c'est également le
cas du parti socialiste qui s'est coupé
ces dernières années de cet électorat
des classes populaires
oui d'une certaine manière c'est
également la même problématique à
laquelle est confronté le parti
socialiste avec la des catégories
populaires qui l'ont délaissée au profit
de la france a soumises notamment
revenons sur nicolas sarkozy est ce que
son engagement dans la campagne on l'a
vu à paris on l'a vu dans des
tractations et notamment à marseille à
nice
est ce que ça peut ressouder les
divisions dans une famille politique
comme les républicains c'est précisément
le rôle qu'il cherche à jouer jouer ce
rôle d'unificateur de la famille de
droite ça avance ça peut avoir des
effets très positifs
alors peut-être moins pour rachida dati
qui est une personnalité connue dont la
fidélité sarkozyste est elle aussi
notoire mais bourdais pour des candidats
avec une notoriété plus faibles qui sont
qui n'ont pas exercé des responsabilités
de premier plan le fait d'être soutenus
par un ancien président de la république
c'est un transfert de légitimité qui est
extrêmement positif et puis qui donne de
la force à une campagne électorale au
niveau local en parlais tout à l'heure
de dégagisme est ce qu'il n'ya pas
aujourd'hui quand même une demande des
électeurs d'avoir des nouveaux visages
dans les partis politiques
c'est vrai
c'est peut-être moins vrai que ce qu'on
a pu mesurer il ya deux ans en 2017
à l'époque vous vous souvenez il y avait
une forte attente de renouvellement du
personnel politique qui a eu lieu et
depuis on se rend compte que
l'expérience politique c'est aussi un
point un facteur très important dans la
conduite de l'action politique
donc je dirais que cette attente de
renouvellement même si elle persiste
sans doute elle est plus tempéré que ce
que nous avions pu observer en 2010 est
donc une demande moindre de
renouvellement
c'est du un peu à l'échec finalement du
nouveau monde c'est dû en partie à
l'échec du nouveau monde c'est dû aussi
à la spécificité des des élections
municipales on a vu tout à l'heure c'est
attachement au maire sortant qui fait
qu' on a peut-être moins envie de voter
pour des figures inconnues ou sans
expérience politique
mais on le voit par exemple à bordeaux
de son temps alain juppé était souvent
élu au premier tour c'était vraiment le
fief de la droite à bordeaux mais son
successeur nicolas florian il a du mal
dans les sondages il a du mal à imprimer
auprès des électeurs oui alors c'est pas
la même équation personnelle qui alain
juppé ancien premier ministre ancien
ministre d'état ministre des affaires
étrangères ministre de la défense car
était président de l'ump
c'est vraiment une aussi une figure
majeure un pilier de la droite
évidemment la même équation personnelle
ni la même notoriété entre entre les
deux candidats et puis il peut y avoir
aussi un effet d'usure du pouvoir la
droite dirige bordeaux depuis maintenant
plusieurs décennies
allez on va voir ce qu'il se passe et ce